which type of course
what's your name my name is Semyon Adana
from Brooklyn bestowed born and raised
so my new year's resolution is house my
New Year's resolution is about health
gonna be a vegan I'm gonna stop eating
meat that's one New Year's resolution
this hate animal cruelty and I just
decided to stop eating animal so my New
Year's resolution is to be a vegan and
then be healthy positive my positive
mind says stop he didn't mean that's my
new year's resolution
so what made you shift to that mine
or will maybe shifter the myself of
being a vegan is because you know
animals have souls also I thought about
that think about it
animals have mother father's tool you
know what I mean they're born to the
planet like here is art so I decided to
just change my mindset of being a a
beast and being a more humble person so
you know I just want to be a vegan and
change my the way I you know the what I
put in my body I just want to put better
things on my body that's it my New
Year's resolution is to live better for
God
I want to finish my career all through
the World Cup in Russia Argentina
probably prepare myself for college
probably going next year well my new
year's resolution because my daughter is
going to school next year is to save
every single penny I can and to be much
better about what I do with my money as
far as managing their money because you
know got a set of kids at school
[Music]
my new year's resolution is to stop
chewing tobacco it is not good for you
gotta stop to cut meat out of my diet
completely
[Music]
me actually does more harm than good so
I would like to be a healthier overall
get a job
they both
musician
probably just spend less money I want a
head 5 2
to get more sleep raise the GPA to go to
the gym and get strong because I'm fat
really fat so I'm already in like pretty
good shape I'm having with my body and
stuff but I want to make sure to work
out every day
my days are delicious to get into
college I want to be happier life to get
a new job
I don't know idea to be honest but be be
a good person be kind yeah I want to
become vegan
because I heard so much about how
I don't really like it and I think it's
healthier risk we shouldn't
I don't really have one because you know
how everybody says as new year new me
but like end of the day nobody really
changes everyone is the same yeah do you
own like example so like end of the year
everybody goes like oh posting OD
pictures go like oh it's new year new me
all the
cankers yeah all the book there out of
my way but the end of the day then end
up doing the same book yeah
these resolution
to spread positive vibes I'm really big
with energies and stuff nowadays so I
detect someone's energies off or brings
mine off they out of my life
so this bringing instilling positive
vibes to others as I would want them to
bring them to me
what's up guys my name is Raya and I'm
the owner of this channel I'm also the
person behind the camera and I thought
I'd take a minute to thank all the
subscribers I gained so far and maybe
ask new years to hit the subscribe
button if you liked this episode or if
you're a fan of my channel in general
don't need a lot thank you